President Trump says his next major
priority is lowering the cost of health
care and prescription drugs in his State
of the Union address the president said
that his administration's policies led
to a decline in drug prices last year
and he called on Congress to do more
Tony Zucco poll shows us the challenges
in bringing costs down and the great
distance one family travels for
life-changing medicine Tony good morning
a good morning Americans spend more on
prescription drugs and people pay in any
other developed nation an average of
some $1,200 a year and for some the cost
is so high they're forced to take
extraordinary measures how extraordinary
we talked to one father who in order to
save tens of thousands of dollars on his
son's medication travels to Canada four
times a year so right now I'm paying
$15,000 a year for this medicine which
costs the United States fifty three
thousand dollars a year which I feel is
at best criminal john yeagley says his
21 year old son has a condition where he
started losing his hair around the
seventh grade only one treatment worked
but the drug wasn't covered by eglee's
health insurance so every three months
he drives six and a half hours to Canada
to buy the medicine there's no reason
why an American should pay three times
what somebody in Canada or Europe or
Mexico has to pay that sentiment was
echoed last night by President Trump who
promised to slash the cost of
prescription drugs I am asking Congress
to pass legislation that finally takes
on the problem of global freeloading and
delivers fairness and price transparency
for American patients finally last week
the administration proposed a rule to
lower prescription drug prices by
encouraging manufacturers to pass
discounts directly on to patients
instead of giving those rebates to
middle man known as pharmacy benefit
managers or PBMs it says this historic
action moves toward a new system that
puts American patients first while
bringing new transparency to
prescription drug markets but the PPM's
opposed the administration's plan saying
it will undercut their ability to
bargain with drug makers for
or prices Express Scripts acquired last
year by Cigna is one of the nation's
largest PBMs we get accused of being the
middleman but the reality is the most
sophisticated employers and health plans
employ us to drive better care at a
lower cost in the absence of PBMs
patients and plan sponsors would be
spending literally billions and billions
more on an annual basis the proposal
from the administration would have to be
passed by Congress but even if it passes
consumer advocates recommend you shop
around for prescription drugs the way
you would for any other products prices
can vary by a lot the same medication
could be eight dollars at one pharmacy
and $58 down the street you just don't
know until you ask for john yeagley
reform can't come soon enough
so my son the might the medicine is
priceless I mean it's given him an
entirety entirely new identity I believe
it has meant everything to him it's made
a tremendous difference in his
personality and in his well-being and if
you're wondering if there are lower drug
prices out there our consumer advocates
suggest checking online resources like
good Rx and blink health but even then
those prices may not be the lowest she
says the cash price may be lower than
your insurance price I feel funny even
saying that it sounds like college again
here you know it's not a part for your
car it's not any other product it's
medicine for your body yeah mm-hmm feels
like college did you do well in college
excellent thank you so much